[موسيقى]
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط الصدمه الكبيره
جاءت في الحرب الاسرائيليه وبالتالي هذا
الامر
ضاعف المتاعب على اقتصادات المنطقه عمق
جروح الاقتصاديه للاردن لمصر للبنان
الانخفاض في النشاط السياحي في مصر الاردن
لبنان التي تعتمد بنسب كبيره من ايراداتها
على النشاط السياحي وعلى ايضا مدخولات من
العمله الصعبه هذا انخفض بشكل واضح في
الاردن اكثر من 50% في مصر كذلك وفي لبنان
انخفض باكثر من 70 الى
80% قناه
السويس بالتاكيد ستشكل معضله للاقتصاد
المصري هم ايرادات الموازنه المصريه اهم
ايرادات اهم مصدر للعمله الصعبه ياتي
للحكومه المصريه من قناه السويس قناه
السويس اذا ما استمر احجام شركات الشحن
الكبرى في العالم عن المرور في البحر
الاحمر وقناه السويس ستتاح بنسبه كبيره في
الشهر القادم متوقع ان يكون خسارتها نصف
قيمه رسوم المرور المتوقع ان تكون قرابه
ال 500 مليون دولار في كل شهر هذا اذا ما
عرفنا بانه ايضا ايرادات قناه السويس في
العام الماضي كانت قرابه ال ونصف مليار
دولار الان نتحدث عن ايضا ما حدث لاسعار
السلع والطاقه اسعار ال الطاقه تاثرت في
اسبوع مضى على احجام الشركات عن المرور في
قناه السويس منها شركه نفط
كبرى طبعا اسعار النفط تاثر ارتفاعا هنالك
3 الى 4% ارتفاعا على اسعار النفط قرابه
الثلا دولار على البرميل اضيفت بسبب هذه
الاحداث الغاز ايضا تلقى ارتفاعا بسبب هذه
الاحداث في القاره الاوروبيه قرابه
7% مؤخرا بعد تقلصه من 15 بال الان ايضا
اسعار السلع تتاثر اسعار البضائع تتاثر
سواء القادمه الى الاردن الى لبنان والى
مصر حتى نتحدث عن ارتفاع قيم الشحن وقود
الشحن الذي ستستهلك السفن اضافه مسافه
جديده في الالتفاف حول راس الرجاء الصالح
وافريقيا بدل قناه السويس وبالتالي هذا
اضاف يعني قيم جديده على البضائع متوقع ان
تختلف من بلد الى اخر سواء العقبه في
الميناء الاردني على البحر الاحمر او
الموانئ المصريه الاستيراد من اوروبا او
من اسيا ايضا لبنان التي تستورد معظم
حاجتها من القاره الاسيويه سيكون لها
التاثير الاكبر على الشحن بحيث ارتفعت
قيمه شحن الحاويه من 1000 دولار الى قرابه
ال 2500 دولار اضيف ايضا على الحاويات
التي تصل الى ميناء العقبه الاردني من 100
الى 400 دولار على كل حاويه امتداد هذه
الازمه سيعمق وبالتالي يصبح تاثيرها اكبر
على دول المنطقه منها الاردن ولبنان ومصر
الذي ايضا من المتوقع ان اسعار سلع وغذاء
وهي المواد الاهم بالنسبه للمواطنين ربما
تؤدي الى اضطرابات اجتماعيه في هذه الدول
هذا هذه الاثار الاقتصاديه سيكون لها ايضا
ارتدادات صعبه على الاقتصاد العالمي سوف
تكبح الجهود العالميه في تخ ض معدلات
التضخم ارتفاع اسعار الشحن يعني مزيدا من
التضخم هذا لمسناه في تقطع سلاسل الامداد
في جائحه كورونا وبالتالي بالتاكيد هذا
سيكون له تاثير كبير اعتقد بانه لن يقل عن
نصف بالمئه في معدلات التضخم العالميه
ارتفاعا